[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello my name is cecil slipovic and i'm
musician in residence at yale
university's
fortune of video archive for holocaust
testimonies
this video series is designed as a
companion to our album
where is our homeland which is the first
volume in the archives ongoing effort
to present songs and poems performed by
survivors in testimonies given to the
fortune of archive
over the last 40 years you can learn
more about the project on the archives
website
songs from testimonies.org
where is our homeland songs from
testimonies volume 1
was recorded in 2019 by the cecil
slupovich ensemble
featuring renowned singer sasha luria
craig udelman on the violin joshua camp
on the accordion
keyboards and guitar dmitry ischenko on
the base
and myself on woodwinds the songs in
this collection differ vastly in terms
of style
social and historical background
language and many other aspects
but collectively they create a
multi-dimensional picture
of jewish life before and during world
war
ii in this episode we are going to talk
about
and listen to another song from lubov
case testimony
tucci not buddhism the clouds gather
over buddhist gym
it is noteworthy that the entire fortune
of video archive
music project started in 2018
with lubov's testimony with the cecil
slipovich ensemble featuring the
wonderful and world-renowned singer
sasha luria
we have recorded two albums 26 songs
in total and i'm preparing two other
volumes to be recorded
with really fascinating and unique
repertoire touching buddhism
is a retexting and melodic
adaptation of pavel armand's music and
lyrics for the song
tuchi not gorodham the clouds gathered
over the city
performed by the popular soviet actor
and singer
mark bernese in the sergey youth
cabbages 1938
film celebric sorghum the man
with a gun the song quickly gained
popularity
armand's text conveys the heartbreak of
a young man
who is going to the war and is bidding
farewell
to the young woman he loves the labor
camp version
shared by lubov depicts the horrific
realities of a slave labor
hunger cold lack of basic living
facilities
and the cruelty of the ukrainian guard
step
on the song has a time and feel of a
waltz
one of the most popular genres in the
1930s
soviet urban culture
of
is
[Applause]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
m
[Music]
your wife's testimony and songs offer
important insight into some lesser-known
aspects of the history of the holocaust
while teeming concentration camps gas
chambers
and industrial crematoria still
dominate popular imagery of the
holocaust
debuff's testimony is more
representative of the experience of
soviet jews
who by and large were not deported to
the killing centers
in german-occupied poland instead in the
small towns and cities of ukraine
belarus the baltic states and western
russia
many able-bodied jewish men young
children
and elderly fell victim to mass
shootings during the early months of the
german occupation
surviving adults were condemned to force
labor in the ghettos or small labor
camps
living in constant fear of ongoing mass
shootings
dubois testimony highlights the
experience of jews
in these small virtually unknown ghettos
and camps
where grueling labor and appalling
living conditions led to high rates of
injury malnutrition and disease
buddhist show was the third camp in a
series of labor camps
where german overseers and local politsi
transported lubuf and her fellow
prisoners
as slave rape slave laborers for the
transit highway 4 project
between may 1942 and august 1943
while these jewish laborers were in
theory incredibly valuable for the
german
war effort the nazi regime allowed
so-called
accidental deaths to claim many lives
and the local gendarmerie added to the
death toll with punitive shootings
and camp liquidations of the four songs
that lubov k
shares in her testimony tuccinat
buddhism
offers the most comprehensive summation
of day-to-day life
in the small improvised labor camps
along the transit highway 4.
it recounts the frigid winter conditions
in the
unheated clubhouse where prisoners were
housed
it describes back-breaking labor they
performed
on the transit highway and their efforts
to supplement the meager food rations
with food from the local villagers
it also references the threat of the
cruel guard stephan
who meted out punishment for running off
to the village
despite the song's somber lyrics
takes visible joy in performing it for
the interviewers during her testimony
as they composed this song in the camps
dubois and her fellow prisoners
borrowed the lilting melody of a popular
soviet song
puccinad gordon from the 1938 movie
the man with a gun the fact that the
original performer of the song
mark bernese was a ukrainian jew
was no doubt a point of great pride for
these prisoners
and the melody a welcome reminder of
their lives before the war
for these reasons perhaps the song ends
with a confident assertion
that the tide of the war will turn
victory
will come and joy will be possible
once again
[Music]
you